so the producers here at the pete home
show thought it would be funny to send
me to ski for my first time i've never
skied before so they sent me uh down a
hill off a ramp
into a pool and not on snow that's like
fun to fall on on like plastic grass so
you guys
let's watch what happened
hello everybody it's uh pete and i'm
here with tony and we're in
park city utah park city utah and this
is the utah olympic park splash pool the
writers come up with things to do on the
show that i don't want to do and other
times there are things that i want to do
my idea for a segment was learning how
to nap when you're not tired well pete
we're up here we're sitting down this is
the easy part right this is we back we
made it up we made it up why do people
want to go there fast let's stay here
and look at bert i keep waiting for
someone to go just kidding we don't have
to do this nope this is it i signed up
for a talk show not a do show
get on the stick
nice work
all right here we are at the top of the
ramp even though i kept eating it uh on
the baby ramp tony here thinks it's uh
okay for some reason for me to go on the
big board that's not what i said but
we're gonna send you anyway love that
can i get the may the force be with you
uh may the force be with you and good
luck and god speed
that's what i'm talking
i mean about
no
sorry that that feels dirty obviously
that that wasn't me that was
definitely not me that was a stunt guy
but they still made me go off the jump i
did go off the jump but it didn't look
quite as good here's here's what it
looked like
fun terrifying